[Music]
neighbors everybody talking about this
movie
yeah it's great yeah and and this is
very exciting you're in this and you had
your first sex scene in this movie
that's right yeah yeah I am
my first sex scene where I show my butt
and I was pretty nervous because my my
butt doesn't look like yeah yeah it's
like the office nobody's butt looks like
yeah yeah it's like he tied a piece of
furniture to that - exactly yeah my yeah
you just mind like that was more the
opposite of yours really it's like a
flat and his pale like blindingly pale
as glass yes yes yeah oh my mind goes in
you can keep it concave but yeah that's
like yeah keep a change in there you
know whose coins anyway you go ahead so
so like I said I was pretty nervous for
the scene and you know I was like
alright just don't overthink it let's
get through this and it seemed to be
going pretty well and then the issue
you're there you're with this actress
record actress of course I'd like met
her that week you know it's always
awkward you got like 20 crew members
standing around who you would also met
that week watching you guys just grind
on each other and then you know a couple
a couple takes in the director comes
into the room and he has this very
pensive look on his face and you can
tell he's trying to like articulate how
you know how to get this note across to
me finally he says Dave maybe just um
more Jackrabbit like cool man so not
only do you see my flat pale ass BC
moving as fast as humanly possible on
top of that the other he thought you
weren't doing it correctly that's got to
be an incredible oh dear
I mean exactly that first someone to
come in and comment on the way that you
do what many people consider the most
important and you know I don't know if I
should trust his taste though because
the one other note he gave me was to
actually flex while I was doing it and
so and ultimately he didn't leave it in
the film because it looked like I was
gonna hit the girl so yeah I'm gonna you
don't flex during sex do you is that
always yes constantly doing lots of
weird contortions right right no yeah
that's just my thing and it's a no one
seems to like it
how about Seth Rogen Seth Rogen I've
known that guy for years of course you
get to work him in this movie and he's
got the most infectious laugh of anyone
I think I've ever met it's true it's
it's very it just makes you feel warm
you know get him to laugh you just you
know you've you've won in life and so
I've realized recently that I too have a
pretty distinguishable laugh but I think
it has the opposite effect of sets
because mine sounds like I'm choking or
suffocating like right right so if I
mean for example I was I was in line for
food recently and I was with my buddy
and we're joking around laughing and the
woman in front of us turned around and
she looks at me and she's like is that a
sick cough I was like no I'm just
enjoying life if I'm in the moment and
you were happy
hey right but like it makes me think if
I loved her choking to death like no
one's gonna help me they're all gonna be
sitting back and like I don't know what
he's laughing about but I want in on
that joke